aussi près que ça allait les mamies
super d'arc à dar k aussi parce que
parce qu'un bon barreur c'est physique
bien simple quand le fromage cool avec
la sauce les trésors que juste radar car
parce que la carte au trésor
alors j'adore les trésors et j'espère
qu'on va les trouver la musique techno à
cedar cap en fait parce que je suis
assez fan un peu restreint quand même
j'ai jeu par exemple la course à pied je
suis incapable de courir sans attendre
un point de côté et sans cracher les
poumons alors que je sculpte pas plutôt
dark a pas ce que parce que sincèrement
je ce serait faux cul te dire que je
regarde jamais gibert dance à saddar cas
parce que il fait hurler de rire et je
trouve que c'est google temps comme les
énerve certains moi je ils font beaucoup
mieux ou plutôt rhin sera parce que je
suis pas trop fan le rap plutôt dark
heart parce que mon épouse
[Musique]